I have revised my prediction I'm going
to beat Gary Vaynerchuk to 1 million
subscribers and maybe even tie Lopez -
what's up Aleve nation at seven my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
you what I see in you you'll be able to
change the planet now I'm a little bit
sick today just recovering from a really
bad stretch of constant fever so I'm
excited to be back and I started this
series about how to get 1 million
subscribers to document my journey along
the way I think I started this series
and I had about five hundred fifty
thousand subscribers last video I had
775 subscribers and that were well over
800 and the goal was really to kind of
show you what I'm doing to build my
channel how to get forty to fifty
thousand subscribers a month and grow
and try to build a million subscriber
channel and you guys could hopefully
learn through that process as well if
your goal is to build a successful
YouTube channel so today I'm going to
compare my channel again to Gary
Vaynerchuk and now also to Tai Lopez a
little bit of background
Gary's friend of the channel he's
interviewed on a channel collaborated
with him for a number of years way back
before even had a YouTube channel I'm
sure Gary doesn't really care about who
hits 1 million subscribers first it's
just a fun little competition it's nice
having something to go ahead to head
with ty I don't really know we did a top
10 on him I'm not super familiar with
this channel but I'm going to dive into
some of the details today and we'll see
what we can uncover ok so back in April
I made a video saying that Gary
Vaynerchuk was going to pass me on
YouTube and I'd have to make a video in
a few months to say Gary Vee passed me
and now he's going to pass me you look
at the curve he's catching up and he's
on the path to beat me and so I'm going
to making a video in a couple months
saying
Gary's ahead of me and I'm now not the
number one channel for entrepreneurs out
there in the world and I got off my game
it's great well fast forward to August
he hasn't passed me yet and I don't
think it's going to happen anytime soon
let me show you why okay so here's the
comparison of my channel versus Gary
Vaynerchuk on social blade and if we go
down to look at the head by head
comparison
as you can see at the very start so I'm
the red line musically line if this goes
leaving before Gary had a bigger
audience and I did and then I passed by
him and then there's this huge gap that
started to open up right huge gap of
what about a hundred thousand or so what
do we add here let's look at this
I was 424 used 334 so you know 90,000
subscribers huge gap big aphek gap and
then he starts to post two videos a day
three videos a day and he starts
catching up he starts closing that gap
closing that gap closing that gap to the
point here which is what June so I said
in April that in a couple months that he
would pass me it's pretty close in June
he's six thousand behind 5,000 behind
six thousand behind he's really
narrowing that gap to five thousand
behind he got within five thousand and
now look what's happening the gap is
getting bigger again to the point where
now is it recording this video he's at
791 I'm at 817 so that's what 26,000 a
gap and getting bigger more important
like he's kind of leveling off and I'm
going up so there's two main reasons why
this is happening and a short-term thing
that's negatively impacting Gary's
channels that I want to talk to you
about so the first thing I look at is
the frequency of uploads on Gary's
Channel one of the main reasons why he
was able to catch up to me was because
he was making two to three videos a day
and he slowed down he slowed down and is
what YouTube want YouTube wants people
who are making consistent content now
we've slowed down to one a day which
isn't that bad but it's not two a day
and there's a big gap between going a
couple times a week to once a day but
there's still a gap between one and two
a day and Gary is falling down right now
maybe it's a summer thing maybe that's
another reason for doing it maybe
there's people on this team that are
shuffling around but if we look at how
many videos are we cold one two three
four five six seven seven videos last
week one two three four five six seven
seven videos a week
four one two three four five six seven
eight videos the week before she's down
to video day and that's still really
really good with you to della rhythm but
it's not to a day and so it's going to
slow his growth compared to someone
who's making more consistent content
recent number two is what I said back in
April about me needing to up my game
it's really really important to look at
your YouTube channel in every individual
series and if they are performing for
you or not so as an example if I pull up
Gary's channel he's got a lot of
different series right he's got his
askgaryvee calling show or however he's
doing it episode 259 episode 261
absolute 260 he's got his daily B's that
that happened on a consistent basis is a
daily vlog show so I know it was five
times a week typically he has this
fireside chat he's got random interviews
that happened and so he's got this
mishmash of different series and what's
really important to look at are these
series performing for you or not I want
to show you something I've never shown
people before this is how I run my
youtube channel this is real data with
the names of the series removed and so
what's really important here is looking
for us at two key metrics watch time and
subscribers every series that we put out
is measured according to watch time and
subscribers watch time because that's
what YouTube really cares about if you
are generally a lot of watch time on
your videos you're going to get more
attention from YouTube and subscribers
because I want my series to benefit the
channel not that my channel has lots of
watch time but I want subscribers to be
coming to it so this is one series this
is another series this is another series
this is another series this is another
series and every month we look at the
data to see how it's going and I only
look at the data for that month because
a video that did well really a long time
ago our Steve Jobs top 10 real success
formula views I don't want that
corrupting kind of my new data I want to
know that my top 10 series is still
performing well that
what of a new top ten it's still
performing well and that we're not just
relying on the old stuff and so as an
example this is a series that we're
looking at today here this is it this is
the path to 1 million some are in our
first video against Eric Thomas it
generally is 13,000 minutes of watch
time and eight subscribers in the month
now since that month that's probably
generated a little bit more for us but
again in that one month the second was
Gary be that one did better fifty-five
thousands watch time fifty nine new
subscribers the next one was Grant
Cardone 27,000 watch time thirteen new
subscribers and then the most recent one
that we did before this we don't have
full data on yet so it's not in here but
that's how well the series does so I
know if I'm putting out a video okay
it's going to generate you know between
thirteen and fifty five thousand minutes
of watch times going to give me between
eight and fifty nine new subscribers and
you know I want to think okay if that's
going to be a daily series if I was
doing this more than once a month
I'd have to optimize that because that
these numbers are not good compared to
some of these other numbers right if a
series here is generating 285 minutes of
watch time and this one only is 27,000
I'm thinking I don't want to keep this
anymore or I need to make this better
and so the things that's really helped
my channel recently is one looking at
underperforming series and canceling
them so you know you see blank spots
here because those are canceled series
that we destroyed all of these blank
spots were canceled series that we
destroyed so we have lots of data for
all these ones as we kept them and this
one was a relatively new one and all
these are the ones have been cancelled
so it's underperforming it goes some of
these are new texts so these are bubble
series when when I say on the video that
I'm not sure if we're going to keep this
series or not it's legit it's true we
may not keep it or not you know right
now whatever series this is to generate
37,000 minutes of watch time and only to
new subscribers that's not cutting it
for us so in our test series we'll do
three I'll do three versions of
something
we'll see we get enough data on it see
if we can move that number up and if we
can we keep it if we don't we kill it so
why has my channel grown recently what
is attributable to the new spike let me
show you on this side here so one was
killing off the bad series - this when
it's purple like that that represents
the best series for subscriber growth in
the month so you can see the dates here
so from you know June the July as an
example this series this series and
these three series all of the highest
subscriber growth look at this series
here this series had a history of
underperforming eight thousand twelve
thousand nine thousand nine thousand
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh buhbuh is 22 not bad
boom seventy-seven thousand minutes of
watch time subscribers you know two
three two two one
thirty-six subscribers this is per video
so 36 new subscribers for every video in
this series that I'm doing now if this
is a once a month series that's not that
big a deal if that's a once a day series
that's a much bigger deal you know like
our top ten series comes out five times
a week and I could do 5 times 36 that's
a good number
right so this series did really well and
so what we're doing is look at this
year's okay how do we tweak it how do we
make it better how do we improve it
because we're looking at watch time and
subscriber growth will mean a few
changes BAM big growth same thing with
this series here 55,000 minutes of watch
time
that's the decent series you know nine
nine subscribers per video in the first
month decent series but look what
happened we made some tweaks and changes
from 55 to 448 from 9 subscribers to 378
per video that we put up in that series
this one also had a big jump ninety five
thousand two hundred and ninety thousand
average doubling the watch minutes per
video and and more than doubling the
subscribers
so it might be kind of a confusing graph
to look at and I don't blame you and
YouTube doesn't really give you those
tools built-in we have to kind of make
custom reports and sift through the data
but that's what my team and I look at
every single month
we want to make sure that every single
series is performing and if it's not
done as a reason right and I've talked
about this on previous series as before
is this a reason to have a video that is
going to underperform that's okay but
you know that there's a reason for right
so an example you're going to make a
sales pitch I'm going to come on in sell
my book right buy this book it's the
greatest book ever right some of you
guys will love that
but it won't be the highest video on my
channel and may even lead to negative
subscriber growth that's okay because
it's serving a different purpose right
I'm serving a business purpose so
whenever you do a sales pitch kind of
video you can expect your numbers to
tank and feed and loose and subscribers
that's okay because you're generating
some revenue from it right but it's the
the other one there is a killer it's the
ones that you think are helping you grow
your channel but are actually hurting
you but if you can find ways to either
adjust or tweak that series will kill
them off your channel really start to
take off now the third thing is going to
hurt Gary in this race that he doesn't
know about is that is that he's going
away he is away right now he is not
making videos and well-deserved family
vacation you'll need to time off and I
applaud that it becomes a challenge
especially this for a vlogger to go away
friend of you guide to our vloggers
unless you're vlogging your vacation and
then it might be some amusing content
some new content out of your city but in
general it's hard to get time off
because the content is so dependent on
you and showing your life the other
sucky could have done in advance like it
could have lined up askgaryvee five
shows film them all in one day and then
release them over time what happened
last year and what's probably going to
happen this year was just his team did a
mismatch of some old stuff couple minute
clips put them together that weren't
very good
and as a fan of the channel fan of
Gary's channel I was like okay when's
Gary coming back on some new stuff I
want the real deal and maybe it seems
much better this year who knows he's put
a lot more time into building his team
and so we'll see what happens
I chose take a look on the channel
because he just recently ran away let's
see so this is Gary's channel so here it
is signing off for a month
then they show some ad tech conference
you did great a keynote perfect and then
see this is business of stuff that will
kill your channel this 2 minute 2 minute
at least he's posting consistently at
least it's still going on but YouTube
right now
from an algorithm perspective does not
want to see these short videos this will
kill the channel these will get some
decent views but will have terrible
watch time and will start to drag down
the channel and it's going to make it
harder for Gary when it does come back
to make it awesome now a lot of people
say so what August is a slow time people
go away you know it's okay for your
chance to drop down obvious doesn't have
to be a slow month August has been a
great month for me so far was last year
- let's look at the data so this is the
social blade for my account if I go down
to see August you know August last year
was better than my July and better than
my June and was the same as my September
and the same as my October almost back
for the August now we can't see because
it's not done yet but looks like July
July was my best month ever July was my
best month ever with growth with with
subscriber growth with views and August
I'm recording this August 15th look at
the August numbers already last 30 days
so 46,000 subscribers last last 30 days
and July was 44 so sorry
it's a record month it's a record month
already in August and and June is a
record month so it doesn't have to be a
slowdown remember what happened in July
July with a record
month for me despite almost all the
videos having terrible sound you guys
killed me for the sound on the videos
good orderly nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems
you killed me on the sound and and
rightfully so like I have standards I
want to produce good quality stuff for
you that's not acceptable to have really
bad sound but despite having really poor
sound right which you think make a worse
video but consistently keeping to what
the YouTube algorithm wants and making
the three videos a day we had our best
month ever
we had the worst sound ever and we had
our best month ever now we fixed the
sound I run track for an even better
month ever and it's August and so it's a
tip not just for YouTube but in business
while your competition is away on
vacation and sleeping and taking time
off and it's a slow time that's the time
when you muscle that's the time when you
can get to work and do amazing things I
used to hate August and December in
general in my business because people
wouldn't return phone calls you couldn't
get business done and I realized this is
my time to plan this is my time to
really hustle and grind so that when
September does come around I'm going to
be firing on all cylinders I'm going to
be way ahead of everybody else now
luckily with YouTube you can still have
an amazing August not have to wait for
anything so whenever you see your
competition going to sleep that's your
chance to attack and get it so that's
what happened with me versus Gary B our
graphs are certain to go apart it's
going to get even bigger picks everyone
he's going to be away for the next
little bit
Gary's gonna have to come back and just
absolutely destroy and get back to
really making two videos a day here if
you want to win you want to get to that
million first two videos of amazing Gary
Vee content every single day when I come
back in September we're going to come
with some real fire on YouTube so you do
get ready
spend this time entertaining some time
to really come back with a 4.0 version
of what we're doing here are listed Tai
Lopez now people been asking about tithe
they wanted my thoughts on his channel
any breakdown and advice I could offer
so let's look at highs Channel now at
the top of the show I said I might beat
Tai Lopez to 1 million subscribers you
go to the social blade and you see that
he's at nine hundred and eighty-nine
thousand subscribers you think well how
are you going to be tied to 1 million
when he's already at 989 Tai runs his
YouTube channel a lot differently than
most people and so this is why let's
look down you look at a social blade he
is not really growing right the past
week it's been all negative except for
today where he had a little bit of
growth and if you look at the growth
history here this is his views and this
is his subs Tai doesn't get his
subscribers from his content tied get to
subscribers him as advertising and so
entire decides to just produce content
he actually loses subscribers when taya
decides to advertise a lot he gain
subscribers and so he obviously has a
way to be able to make money from his
channel right it funnels to his various
courses programs and I don't know
anything about those programs I can't
you know recommend them or not but it's
working you know it's making money from
it it's working so he's going to
continue doing it so let's look at the
history of his channel so he's fooling
around here he's got a million views a
month a million views a month and then
BOOM
what month is this September 2015
95.7 three million views this ladies and
gentlemen is to here in my garage
campaign right if you look at the here
in my garage ads this is when it was
launched and so he went from you know
one to ninety five million views that he
bought so he basically bought ninety
five million views now if we go down to
his subscribers you see that it led to a
nice chunk of new subscribers right he
said fifty nine thousand sixty-four
thousand subscribers so he bought a
chunk of subscribers but he wasn't
getting that many
more subscribers from that video
compared to what he had before you know
to go from 5964
down to 20,000 so he you know he spent
how much money to buy 95 million views
to get an extra 35 40 thousand
subscribers but I guess it worked out
for him right everybody has seen that
commercial and he was able to funnel
them into different advertising courses
for himself what's really interesting is
as we fast-forward down to here you look
at January 2017 he had this huge surge
in subscribers
he jumps two hundred and fifteen
thousand new subscribers with almost no
huge growth here on his views he wasn't
spending the money on his views up here
anymore so he spent in different ways
either it's off platform spending on
Instagram or Facebook ads or is looking
at pre-roll ads that don't count towards
the view count of the video so it's not
really leading to a lot of new views on
this channel with leading to a lot of
new subscribers for him and so you can
see the once he shuts off his
advertising it just falls back down so
it's really hard to predict what's going
to happen how do you go from a channel
have a hundred fifteen thousand new
subscribers in January down to having
four hundred new subscribers you know
six months later how do you have a
channel that is losing subscribers on
most days just from organic video it's
really at the tie went I want to spend
money in advertising his channels going
to explode and when he doesn't then
attend the channel is going to surface
Inc and so it's just a different model
than what most youtubers do we typically
grow to the content that we create and
tie his found his own unique places
saying that through advertising can
build his own little Empire off of it so
those are my quick thoughts me versus
Gary Vee vs tyloo PES we'll see who hits
1 million first between the three of us
I'm excited it's all fun anyway there's
no real stakes on the line but it's nice
to see have a little bit of competition
as we all grow together to try to help
the entrepreneur community now let me
hand up some questions and see what you
got from last
so the most liked comment from last
month's video from C&D amede Sohail you
don't have million subscribes triple
exclamation point that's a that's a
fantastic point I'm glad that that's
what you took at a at a last video it's
really interesting to see what people
take away from content like I use a kind
of person who finds the truth and things
or just finds one little kind of detail
to pick out and just be a naysayer all
the time I acknowledge it every series
that this is about the path to getting
two million subscribers and also you
mean you have to point of that last
video how's that seven hundred and
seventy five thousand subscribers what
are you at CMV Amin Sohail zero zero
subscribers so someone who is seventy
seven point five percent along the way
the hidden a pretty big goal maybe
there's still something you can learn
from them and not just shut down next
Zee ghost blood underscore not being a
hater but Grant Cardone say don't get
advice for someone who never get it yet
it's the same thing I think it's the
same comment right well first of all go
watch the Grant Cardone video because
Grant Cardone said that everybody should
listen those advice grant cardone said
thanks having great job and great
content let's do a podcast on this this
is how you add value folks watch what
evan is doing here all caps smart so the
ghost blood underscore a few men you
could focus on the fact that I'm not at
a million subscribers yet or you can
actually sing a grant cardone because
grant gets it if there's good advice in
the videos because it's way ahead of
where you're at if this is your goal or
not all right moving on soul lovely
thank you for not putting any background
music on this video you're welcome mr.
bill my prediction Bevins channel 1
million subscribers on tour on the 25th
of October 2017 damn that's fast that's
fast social blade has me let me see so
if you go to future projections here to
show you when they think you're going to
hit it you go subscriber milestones
social blade thinks I'm going to hit a
million in 118 days December 12 December
11th December 11th would be an early
Christmas present for me but I would
love to be October 25th medival let's
make that happen that'd be great
next up practical psychology have been
something I've been thinking about
instead of two to three videos a week or
even one video week I've been thinking
about stockpiling some videos and
posting them all the november/december
for 50 to 60 videos in a row your
thoughts the argument could change by
then and I also wouldn't get instant
feedback with daily videos for 60 days
on an animation channel with high your
attention would be some amazing data I
like it I would only say like don't stop
doing what you're doing right now and
and don't stop it in December build the
machine just think about what do I need
to do to make an animation video every
single day you know I can't make a video
myself when I was doing everything
myself I could do one a week just the
editing took way too long in a research
took way too long get in front of the
camera in talking I could do kind of
this kind of video every day but the
videos that I wanted to make I couldn't
do every day so I build a team so if
you're making animation videos we're
thinking what's your key role in it are
you
animating are you doing the store behind
you are you're doing the researching are
you doing the titling we're moving right
now you're doing everything and start to
think what is the most time-consuming
thing that is involved in your channel
that you don't want to do and then find
someone to help you do that as soon as I
found an editor for my channel is able
to go to one
video a day I made the world of
difference so that's what you need to
find next up Samar ki can uploading
daily or even twice daily actually hurt
you sometimes I wonder if I'm pumping up
too much content that my subscribers
can't keep up
I currently post one times a day and
live stream one to three times a week
for the record I'm a gaming channel
centered around one franchise the sim on
debating whether I should take it down a
notch from your advice you're saying I
should just
I should double it just curious if I can
hurt some channels or it's always better
to post more so it's always better to
post more if it's good that's the tough
part you know anybody can just throw up
two videos a day or three videos a day
even when I was posting the videos with
poor sound back in July they were still
good but when I showed you my series
right in that excel chart or Google Docs
we kill series all the time the ones
that aren't performing well we kill and
so we're paying really close attention
to is this series that I'm putting out
working or not other things keep in mind
don't expect your audience to keep up
stop worrying about your audience
watching every single video it's not
going to happen I don't care if you guys
watch every video on my channel I don't
need you to watch every video on my
channel I don't want you to watch every
video on my channel I want you to watch
a video watch the ones that mean
something to you and then go do
something about it and so we'll be
looking at okay it does not matter to me
if my subscribers watch every video that
I have as long as every video is leading
to growth and is successful the other
thing live stream is its own algorithm
live stream is a whole different beast
and so what really happens in the live
stream did you get a lot of live
attention right away but the replay
value is really low you'll find that the
live videos are not watched much after
the fact unless you're really promoting
them somehow they don't they don't live
for very long and so if you're doing one
post a day and live-streaming one to
three times a week I wouldn't count the
live streams really as as posts as
videos I've been looking at making
sure that you're posting one quality
video a day and if you have a live
stream that's a great extra piece of
content I'd make sure the live streams
aren't hurting you because the live
streams are hurting my channel if I have
a big name that came on my channel then
it would help the channel but if I had
someone who's never been on camera
before I had somebody that you know
people had no idea who they were it
would actually lead to negative
subscribers and says why she started a
second channel Evan Carmichael live for
any of the live stuff that isn't with a
well-known personality so I'm just again
look in your data look at analytics use
the same metrics that I gave you watch
time per series subscriber growth per
series if you can look at those videos a
day are they all this is the exact same
video each time are they can you have
different themes and then within each
theme which things are forming well with
watch time and subscriber growth from
which things aren't kill off the ones
that aren't doing well and the live
streams - if you live in to watch time
for your channel is a leading subscriber
growth so the two most important metrics
I'd be looking at more content that is
quality I would make five videos a day
if I could I just can't I can't make it
quality I could throw up five videos a
day I would lose a bunch of people
because the three videos I'm making are
really good but the fourth wouldn't be
as good and the fifth wouldn't be as
good so that's a challenge but if I
could find a way to make five really
good videos a day I'll do it Jay here I
found out about your channel because of
prism command subscribe because your
videos are inspiring from my mind
towards increasing my clientele I really
like your attitude around business thank
you for that Jay her Charlie is awesome
from Chris on command and I'm glad
you're here welcome to Blue Nation chart
your trade in one of your videos you
debunked that no video should be greater
than six minutes long my question is
what do you think the minimum length of
a video should be right now if you want
to do well with YouTube's algorithm you
want to be looking at 10 to 12 minutes
long video at least that's what they
want that's
I want to go to Gary's Channel and see
what it's doing her strategy when he's
away and they're posting these two to
three minute video it's going to hurt
his channel even if it's good stuff like
it has to be it's not that no two-minute
video can do well you can go to the
trending time and see one really short
video but it used to be still like
YouTube trending used to always really
short little bloopers little fails to
cat videos 30 second recording 59 second
recording - trying to get it under one
minute as much as possible because
people have short attention spans this
has changed it's not what YouTube wants
to promote they want to promote watch
time and so if a video even my-my-my six
minute video that was too long now
I have to I would want to make it ten
minutes the business that's done you
know two million views plus for me now
did well in an environment where shorter
videos were rewarded more now you want
to be in the 10 to 12 minute range per
video ideally you can win again if it's
shorter but you're just playing against
the algorithm has to be so insanely
overwhelmingly good that it busts
through the algorithm you could still
win a race barefoot the why not wear
running shoes right so I'd be looking at
10 to 12 minutes next up christ-centered
ironworks Haven I've been watching your
videos for a while now ever since
hearing about you from Roberto Blake
awesome welcome aboard between the two
of you your advice has helped me grow my
channel from 2,500 subs to 4600 subs in
the last two months by applying your
teachings specifically we started
posting two times a day hmm
imagine that so you keep almost doubled
this channel in two months by posting
twice a day and my views went from 2,500
a day to 6,500 a day at first glance
this might not seem like huge growth for
some channels but I am an artist
blacksmith I have a very small niche
channel so it is huge to me thank you
for all you're doing on YouTube hope
this finds you well god bless and this
so this is the difference guys so many
of you are not even trying it
there's a chunk of you who just say oh
this guy Anson 10 million subscribers
someone's going to discount everything
that he's saying perfect there's a whole
other chunk we'll find out some other
reason to discount everything I'm saying
great then there's going to be a chunk
of you who will say well I can't do that
find all the reasons why this strategy
stupid is not going to work it's not for
me I can't do it buffa buh-buh-bah
excuses excuses reasons up above about
great so you're going to have the small
few and these are the guys I mentioned
making this video for the small few to
say huh that's interesting how about I
give it a shot
you get this guy who doubled his channel
almost triples the views in two months
just by trying just by going into a day
so many people are so quick to discount
an idea without even trying it I'm
telling you this is helping that will
work for you even if you are less
talented than the people above you my
channel continued to grow despite all
those sound issues because our best
month ever because we're playing to
YouTube's algorithm this is what
YouTube's want right now again 2018 may
be different probably will be this is
what's working right now and it behooves
you to actually just give it a shot just
how about you try it before you start
hating on or just rejecting it flat out
next up Ryan Bishop a up in quick
question celebrity endorsements and
collaborations how did you make contact
did you message shift accept any reply
or you made the video and he just hoped
he would see it so for most of these
it's starting to change a little now but
for most of them I never make contact
but it also didn't surprise me that they
would share it I would always make
something that that I'm proud of and
that if they saw they would be proud of
it so when we made the 50 cent video
before we press publish this if 50 saw
this would he be proud of it what he
wanted to show it off because we're
always trying to put people not
necessarily just put them in a
the plight but we want to share their
best knowledge the best thing that they
have to say we've sifted through hours
and hours and hours of research of
interview that they've done that pulled
together the 10 nuggets that they've
said over the course of their career and
so it's a tribute to them and their
advice and their wisdom and so I never
reached out to 50 cent to say hey can
you share this but it didn't surprise me
never surprise me ever when any of these
people share their videos because it was
made that way with intention that if
they saw it they would want to share
next up Valerie while Ivan thank you for
confirming what I knew to be true great
quality content daily easier said than
done that's true what hacks if any can
you offer about how to accomplish two
great quality videos daily I've heard
about using batching what other tips
tricks tools of the trade work for
Korean daily quality content also do a
lot of live streams on my channel and
shop to find out from you here that is
not the best thank you again and I'm one
to take action on what you shared here I
love a Valerie yes I love it okay so
tricks to creating content daily vacuum
is definitely important so batching is
basically taking the tasks that you're
doing repeatedly and crunching them into
one so for me I used to film every
Wednesday and now I film once a week for
the most part sorry once a month for the
most part on a Wednesday that's why when
my sound went out it impacted so many
videos because the sound was out for
pretty much the entire recording day and
so every in spresso every top 10 every
mentor me you know the same issue with
the sound and then when I filmed it
again the next month everything was
fixed so now the new ones coming out
have better audio so I definitely be
looking at backing the recording time
batching the researching so think about
your typical process if it's like
research and then record and then edit
if I want to make 2 videos a day I'd be
trying to think about how do I record
those 14 videos in one day
so I've been looking at recording in one
day to get that done how much research
do I need to do before so do you need
one day research you need to do the
research and III do some research
do you need to have somebody help you
with the research then in the post in
editing this is what it becomes insanity
the editing is just a crazy long process
how much time you need and I'd be
looking at how do I bring on somebody to
help me
so batching first then building a team
underneath is going to help me whether
that is somebody who you hire whether
you go to some place like up work and
hire a part-time editor to assist you
whether that's a friend who volunteers
and contributes a friend a family member
a client we can maybe exchange services
with if they do the editing for your
channel and you help them with whatever
you know product or service that you're
selling building a team becomes
paramount I could not do this without my
team you know we have eight people work
on the YouTube side of things for me
that's how I make three videos a day you
know I've two and a half editors on my
team I have a person whose sole job is
to go and do research you know people in
the comments a cameraman obviously so
building a team is going to be super
important to your process and then I've
been thinking about new series what kind
of consistent new content can you come
up with on a regular basis that doesn't
require in the moment thinking because
you're thinking oh it's my books are
really going to be about I have to
record it today it's really not going to
be you know super high quality stuff but
if you're in advance thinking ok I need
to come up with three new series for the
next month that's going to come out what
am I going to do what's what am i
serious going to be what am i interested
in how I'm going to document that and
then paying attention each series of
teeth is working like this is just about
how to create the content then you got
to make sure the content is working
right it's got to be delivering and
performing for you so comment about the
live streams
just unfortunate I love live streaming I
love live streaming because it's so
great to interact with the fans with you
guys at the audience
it's just how YouTube works they give
you a big boost but the replay value
isn't great and so if you're really good
like if you really wanted to go twice a
day and you can pull this off and you're
great in front of the camera and you
need minimal editing I would even use
the YouTube live tools is what I'm doing
right here right now I'm recording this
using the YouTube live tool but it's not
being broadcast live to you it's being
broadcast as an unlisted video and then
my editor is going to pull this save it
mash it up pull it all the lumps and
ahhs and I think Austin like crazy you
guys as my heretic ISM I'm sick and you
don't want to hear that stuff but
there's another one she's going to cut
out all that stuff and then put together
a final video but you could do it as a
live video to unlisted and then release
that as a video and it would do better
then if you released it as a live video
itself it sucks it's just the way
YouTube's algorithm works I wish to
change it I've been trying to figure out
a better live strategy for myself and
talk to all the YouTube guys and unless
you're in gaming there's no real major
application yet for live and that that
really sucks but I'm working on trying
to figure something out
next up Michael Jordan Michael Jordan
ladies and gentlemen why you say this
can apply to other social media
platforms every social media platform
has an algorithm and you just need to
understand how the algorithm works the
posting three times a day may not work
everywhere
I'm not saying posting three times a day
works Twitter or to Instagram or to
Facebook or to snapchat you probably
need to post a lot more to be honest if
you look in the other platforms but it's
understanding the platform's algorithm
to real win within it because you can
win on on your talent and you can win on
your looks and you can win on your
message if you can win a whole bunch of
different things
but you can also win by being worse at
all of that stuff and just understanding
how the algorithm works for that social
media network so I know YouTube best I'm
trying to share the advice that's
helping me quickly build my youtube
channel but you can use the same metrics
to figure out and deconstruct how other
social media networks work Facebook is
in a great example because it's a paid
platform right now you know to try to
get organic reach is not it's not the
game in facebook so let's go to
Instagram look at Instagram and I don't
have a major presence on Instagram I
haven't really focused a lot of
attention on Instagram so I've been
looking at what hashtags don't want to
be a part of had attached and culture on
Instagram you have to pay really
important attention to the hashtags I'd
be looking at how many times should I be
posting pictures now my most in the
picture once a day twice a day 10 times
a day you know you can start by
deconstructing who are the people that
you look up to and respect on Instagram
and then see how often they're doing it
and then try and if someone's at five a
day you start by matching add anything
what happens if I go to six a day why
does it go to two a day
and then you look at your different
series okay so I have one series of
motivational quotes another series of
pictures and other series that's you
know selfies of whatever and then you
see this series getting lots of
attention this series is not let's kill
that one okay we're going to kill that
line let's put in a new one what's it
going to be hmm we've got a brainstorm
it's all the same stuff your content
producer just playing the slightly
different algorithm so each social media
platform functions on its own but the
methodology can be applied to all of
them I think the most important part is
just understanding what are the key
metrics that we're chasing and then
optimize for that so for YouTube all I
care about is looking at the watch time
and looking at the subscriber growth and
again this is all within my mission I
want to want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I want to do it the right
way it's all about belief right I could
get to a million way faster by posting
the top 10 stupidest things Steve Jobs
that
in his life right to top the top ten
arguments between entrepreneurs right
it's just that's not me right it's not
my one word it's not what I'm all about
so within your value system right then
you figure out the most important
metrics for that social media structure
and you just attack next up - it does I
was uploading one video per day for like
two months straight and my views went
from ten for an eighty to a hundred
views per day
imagine that then I stopped for three
weeks because I had a test and it
started and I started again three weeks
ago and now I'm on a TDS per day and
growing so it really works a lot
congratulations keep going keep doing it
now make those videos better Sara makes
art I wish I could do daily videos but
I'm barely managing with two and three
edit videos a week I started the live
stream on most days that I don't upload
so at least I would have activity on my
channel most days of the week yeah again
I pay attention to are the live streams
helping your channel or hurting look at
the watch time on them look at the
subscriber growth on them are they
leading to growth to your channel or not
the only danger is sometimes the live
streams as I did on my channel a lot of
them were leading to flat or negative
subscriber growth and so it's why I
killed them and move them to a different
series it's re different Channel this is
important three videos a week that are
good is better than five videos a week
or seven videos a week where half of
them are bad right like again I said I
wish I can be at five video of the day
I'm not because I can't produce five
quality videos a day I keep testing
these series with you guys and a lot of
them just don't pass the mustards it's
just not good enough you don't like them
enough so if you liked all my new series
and I could be at four videos a day five
videos a day you don't like my new
series as much and so I'm constantly
testing new stuff to see if you like
this one I was this one you guys liked
this series how about this series and so
you want to be at at least a video a day
but good that's got to be good stuff so
don't just throw crap at the screen you
are leaders what I'd like to know is
what
actly is the payoff for having a million
or high number of subscribers after
busting ones but to create that much
content for YouTube what we want to get
in dollars and cents a thousand dollars
bi-weekly 750 a week 250 day undergoes
an hour what do you I wanna come down I
wonder contamination depends on how much
you do kind of outside of YouTube if
you're only focused on Adsense it's not
a great business model and you can you
can really ramp up the numbers you can
look at whatever you're making now
whatever your CPM is I think for most
channels it's a dollar 50 to 250
something like that
so you just ramp up the numbers and
that's what you're going to make it
really depends on the niche again I met
some people clamor Khan who had you know
million million subscriber plus channels
and they're still trying to make a
full-time living and haven't hired
anybody in their team and in my business
we've got 8 people on the YouTube side
and I'm not a Tamilian yet right so it
depends on some some markets are easier
to to sell some have more interest from
from brands and have more advertising
dollars flowing into it and some people
are just better entrepreneurs you know I
started this from the beginning as a
business you know it's why I want all
the comments responded to you know these
are our customers with people that we
care about you know it's not just a
hobby for me it would never was just the
hobby it was okay if we're going to do
this it's this part of my business is
part of me making an impact to help
entrepreneurs so there's a lot of
factors that go into it much more than
just how many subscribers that a YouTube
channel has next up two-minute tips
great analysis and thanks for sharing
when you have a niche that's fairly
focused you do get to the end of what
there is to share I've seen a number of
providers in my category come to brick
wall
I challenge now to expand my content
while still making it relevant to the
niche there's got to always be ways to
grow always there ways to learn at the
beginning for any channel you're
auditing mostly beginners right for most
businesses you're honest is going to be
beginners who want to learn something
and they might learn the basics really
quickly
you can do a couple things you can not
just show them to how to's you can bring
on questions from an audience right so
somebody has a question down below you
can always encourage it from your
audience and then go and answer that
question you can do a review of how
somebody is doing your thing I don't
know what it is that you do but you can
do a review how somebody is doing it and
get feedback and tips and advice you can
try to tie it to some local news story
that's happening or an international
news story that's happening you could
try to bring in - you see a famous
entrepreneur or something that you look
up to how they might do it what do you
what do you think that how Steve Jobs
would knit a sweater you know I don't
know exactly what you're doing again you
have you can take requests like if
there's anything art related make it
like this like can you make a portrait
of this person there's always room for
creativity there is always always always
in any field any industry room for
creativity as soon as you say you hit a
brick wall that's your opportunity it's
your opportunity to be more creative and
find another way and that's going to be
your chance to bust through next up
eclectic
Allu so refreshing this really makes
sense I don't think I can upload once a
day but I appreciate honest advice and
having this as a goal is helpful also
thank you for telling me sub4sub guys to
go make good content haha listen this an
honest approach I appreciate that
not everybody can go and make one
quality video a day and that's fine you
don't necessarily need to go out and do
it right now
you know there's a lot of people who
want to start a business which they
could be in a full time but you can't
right now because you have builds the
pain you have a full-time job and you're
doing this in the evenings and weekends
you know that that's understandable
maybe this is realities of life it's
just having it as the goal like this is
where I want to get to and trying to
work towards it if you see it as an
impossibility or you just reject it out
of hand then you're never going to
you're never going to get there all
right but if you see it is okay that's
where I want to be this is this is this
new stage that I had for myself because
we're going to work too
words I'm going to get better at it you
can when I made my first videos it took
me it took me in two days to make one
video you know take a camera in and I
recorded and I would suck a record again
and it would suck in just two days to
make that one video just recording and
now in front of a camera and just talk
because of the repetition you get better
at anything through the repetition you
get better and so what might seem crazy
to make one video a day now if you have
that as your goal you'll find ways to
make it happen doesn't mean you need to
quit your full-time job or make drastic
life changes you'll find ways to get
better you'll find hacks to help you
improve as you do it more and more and
more you will just get faster and more
efficient at it and so I love the
openness and the approach eclectic Allu
and if you can't do it right now
then it's fantastic to have that as your
goal for the future alright guys got
into there don't know how long it's been
it's been a while my throat is burning
thank you for the love on the series if
you have a question like me to answer in
the future version of the how to get to
1 million series leave it down below in
the comments thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon